we are now joined by civil rights leader
and former u.n ambassador andrew young
he helped draft the civil rights act of
1964 and called
john lewis a friend good morning
ambassador
thank you for being with us
even though i'm older than he was
we all know about john lewis the icon
but
he was your friend tell us about him as
your friend
well john lewis was maybe the quietest
member of the civil rights movement he
could laugh
and he could joke but he was very
seldom rowdy allowed
or he had no ego at all he was
he was he had the power of humility
that just one people over to him
he didn't push he wasn't angry
and he had many reasons to be angry
but he was always dominated by that
loving spirit in his life
that um well
there was a power in his humility
just just made people want to follow him
actually i came from new york
go on sir no i moved from new york
back to atlanta in 1961
after i saw a nashville sit-in story on
television
and i had been
in the south before in pastoring little
country churches
but i thought i was
out of the south until he came on
with the nashville sit-in story and
we realized that our place was back
in atlanta
and i got you to come back in fact and
he said
come home and your wife was like i'm
coming
martin luther king jr's legacy has been
with us since he's passing
do you think it will be the same with
congress congressman lewis's legacy
the generations from now will say
and feel the way they do about him
well i think this generation knows john
lewis
and i think that john lewis
and ct vivian who passed day before
yesterday
will be remembered tact for their
tactical
work uh for their philosophical
conversations
but mostly for that non-violent presence
in the face of severe danger
and the willingness to to march
fearlessly through the valleys of the
shadows
did he in fact understand his own legacy
mr ambassador just how many lives he
touched
i think he did because he touched almost
everybody in the house of
representatives during the 34 years that
he served
there and
he campaigned for them in their own
districts
and he's probably been to every state in
the union
campaigning for members of congress and
that was one of
the reasons why he had so much political
and moral
influence because
they knew that what he said he meant
and that he was willing to live and die
by it
so there was a kind of integrity
that you don't find off
there there is a documentary that is out
now called good
trouble and i know that you are a fan so
we will be hearing more about the
congressman
later on in this show mr ambassador we
thank you
andrew young our former ambassador to
the u.n